good morning John I don't know if what
people know about how I make videos but
I usually write a script and this video
doesn't have one of those I started to
document it says good morning John
that's the whole thing that's what I got
basically a lot happening all at the
same time the entire YouTube community
is coming together to raise money to
plant trees in the world which is lovely
I just bought a bunch of land to build a
warehouse on because dftba has grown too
much which I don't mind because as I
haven't I don't think even mentioned on
this channel
dftba now gives all of its profit
distributions that would normally go to
me and john to charity and also yes
that's happened and we've already raised
more than half of our initial goal of
two hundred and forty thousand dollars
at PIH org slash Hank and John have a
big truck where do you do it
where are you going he's gonna okay good
and also it's just a lot to have finally
had this thing that John mostly you but
also I have been working on for a really
long time and like been thinking about
for a really long time this is something
that we've been really careful about in
that if we're gonna ask a lot of people
for a lot of money and it also put a lot
of our money on the line and we want to
do it the right way and we want to have
the best impact that we can now of
course best is a trap that you can get
stuck in right like is this the best
possible use of money that's how you
start thinking about things you will
never do anything because what isn't the
best possible use of money I know this
for a fact is it sitting in my bank
account that's what usually happens when
people have money you put it you invest
it in the stock market and then the idea
is that like in the future that money
will be worth more money and it will be
but as I was getting lots of advice on
what to do with money because this is
like there's a whole industry of people
who are advisors for people who have
money what I was realizing was when I
said like I just want to give the money
away now there was a lot of like well
wait like wait for the money to become
worth more money and then give it away
then it'll be more of a gift you'll give
away more money and that made a kind of
sense until I realized a really obvious
thing poverty and illness and hardship
are taxes that pay for nothing these
things make it harder and less likely
for people to find stability and
contribute to their communities having
your mother die is something that
decreases your odds of finding stability
for your whole life
and my money doesn't disappear when it
arrives in Sierra Leone that value grows
in children and nurses and parents and
communities it just grows in ways that I
can't see or control the way I could if
the money was in a bank account
financial advisors don't love this line
of reasoning because it doesn't make
them any money there are no like highly
paid charity donation advisers though
that's a little bit what John and I are
trying to do for some people just shoot
us an email at Hank and John at
gmail.com we can help you make the most
of your dollars also to raise money for
this we're gonna be going on more tours
if you want to tell us where we should
go there's a link to a map in the
description you can click on where we
should go
it should be fairly self-explanatory
also at complexly we're doing a pilot
season where 2/3 of the way through
right now so we've got 3 shows that
we're making 3 episodes each of and
we're putting them up history pop which
is like exploring history through the
lens of pop culture got a Deadwood
episode and a Chernobyl episode up so
far and then we've got stories retold
which is like an all-ages animated
channel where we retell fairy tales with
like modern morals and then it hashed
out and there's links to all of these in
the doobly-doo we're confronting the
complexities of communicating name 2019
journalism in its Twitter and its bias
and its leaks and all this stuff so the
staff is kind of doing all these
projects at the same time as all of
their normal things but I think that
it's really cool and thanks to everybody
complexly who's working their butts off
and then pizza Miz is happening next
week I got a big pile of Pete some of
stuff right over there that you can't
see yeah you don't know about this it's
the time of year when John and I go back
to like 2007 vlogbrothers and we make
videos every day like we used to
I'll be fine John because pizza miss
starts next week I will see you on
Monday give to Partners in Health or
check out the pilots here